we're in LA for the dunk tank flambe of
creation by two bit circus Eric yeah
this is outrageous acts of science is
very own Eric Redman this is Eric from
our show I'm a boss yes you are
the invention is a spin on traditional
carnival favorites the dunk tank but
instead of water it's fire so when you
hit that paddle it triggers 15 propane
burners to make giant flames completely
engulfing Eric Elvis Chucky wasn't seen
but not this insane so how does our
outrageous boss not get burned
temperatures inside this chamber can
reach 20 350 degrees Fahrenheit or 1300
degrees Celsius so Eric's wearing a
special flame-retardant suit keep them
cool there are clearly the heat from the
outside would be able to reach his body
conduction convection and radiation the
suit slows conduction by serving as a
physical barrier between the wear and
the fire it prevents convection by
preventing hot air from getting inside
and it prevents thermal radiation by
reflecting that radiation out because of
its aluminized coating the fibers in the
suit are also safe although they're
synthetic they don't melt and this means
that you don't end up if they overheat
with a suit of melting plastic all over
your body this is pretty important
walking into the dunk tank flambe for
the very first time was nerve-racking
and I really had to put my faith in the
effectiveness of that suit and thank
goodness it performed perfectly Eric
made it onto this show by feeling the
heat of those flames but I have a much
hotter body